good evening good evening hi I'm
Jacqueline goldsby on professor of
English and african-american studies the
happy instructor of James Baldwin's
American scene and I'm really delighted
to welcome you to the second of our
Frankie lectures in the humanities on
James Baldwin's American scene I'm
really thrilled you're here and I just
want to as a way in to give you a little
bit more background about this series
and to introduce our filmmakers who are
here with us tonight and then we'll
watch this film together and think
together about it as I mentioned this is
the second in a series of lectures that
are sponsored by the Whitney Humanities
Center the Frankie lectures and the
humanities are meant to be a public
outreach arm for a course that is
offered by the Whitney Humanities Center
and this year it happens to be the
course I'm teaching James Baldwin's
American scene tonight we're going to be
screening and watching and thinking with
the price of the ticket which I'll talk
about in a bit but I just want to give
you a heads up for the exciting roster
of talks to come on october 13th will
have at Pavelec from the University of
Georgia to come and talk with us about
Baldwin's relationship James Baldwin's
relationship to music and the ways in
which blues and gospel music informed
his sense of improvisation and his prose
writing style rich blent will be here
with us to talk about another cinematic
side to Baldwin he was a great fan of
American movies and an astute critic of
them if you've not read his essays from
the devil finds work you should but rich
is going to be walking us through the
films that Baldwin saw and looked at and
thinking with us about those on october
18th on october 25th mog deserve rosca
from the University of Michigan who is
probably the foremost
refer of baldwin right now on precisely
because she writes about his years
abroad her book James Baldwin's Turkish
decades about the decade he spent in
Istanbul is brilliant and she'll be here
to talk about his queer home making on
here in the United States and abroad on
the twenty-fifth and then on December
first Chris LeBron who's a colleague
here at Yale a philosopher and in
african-american studies will think
about the concept i think that Baldwin
is probably best known for love what is
his philosophy of love and what does it
have to do with our struggles for social
justice that's on December first all of
these talks raid 5 30 so that hopefully
I wanted to ideally arrange them all on
Thursdays because I think that Thursday
is the new friday at least that's my
hope but some of them are on Tuesdays
some of them are on thursdays but
they're always at five-thirty on to give
us all a chance to to break away from
our work whether that school in an
office or ever life keeps you busy the
rest of the day to come and think about
the world is Baldwin would have us think
about it um there are some thanks I need
to offer up I've been using this phrase
the Frankie lectures in the humanities
and I'm really honored that the
supporters who bear that name Richard
and Barbara Frankie are here with us
today and I'd like you to stand up
um I can't tell you I just want to tell
you face-to-face in front of a crowd of
people it's meant so much to me and so
much to our students to be able to think
as capacious Lee as we're able because
of your support and sometimes Baldwin
writes about this one of the ways in
which I wrestle with the privileges of
what it means to be here at Yale is that
I have access to resources at every
teacher ought to have excellent students
who are capable and bright and skilled
classrooms that are well-equipped
funding to think and not worry about
where the next set of logistics will get
taken care of and you make that possible
this room is this ring key and it gives
me a model for the way in which teaching
ought to happen everywhere in America so
that's the way I make peace with the
privilege that I have to teach here at
Yale it's a model for how it ought to be
done and everyone ought to have this
privilege to and I want to thank you for
committing your money and your support
to supporting the humanities in this way
so thank you I also want to thank the
staff of the Whitney humanity Center for
allowing us to use this great space
director Gary Tomlinson thank you so
much for your support and the expert
Stephanie they have a machine that works
like clockwork it's just it's it's a
pleasure to work with them and I also
want to thank my graduate assistant
Venus Alexander who has skills beyond
belief and I tell them I want to do this
and then this happens you know I'm kind
of technologically challenged also Thank
You Phoenix so you know Charlotte Tulsa
Baton Rouge Minneapolis it's said that
the list can go on and on and on and it
doesn't stop but that's all the more
reason why it's important that we're
watching this film today and that we're
grateful to see it with the filmmakers
who made it
the price of the ticket first aired on
PBS and its American masters documentary
series in 1989 two years after James
Baldwin died nearly more than 25 years
later the film's explanatory power still
indoors I really don't want to say any
more than that because I don't want to
no spoiler alerts I will say this is the
most brilliant film about James Baldwin
that we'll see and it's it's it's it
still moves me it still grips me and it
explains the whole arc of its career in
all of its steps and textures with a
grace with insight and power that's rare
and we're lucky to see it the one thing
I do want to stress though in terms of a
frame for how you might think about what
you'll see is that we we get to watch
how Baldwin chose at every turn in his
life to bear witness to the world around
him he never stood apart from the world
he always stepped in and took action in
it and given what we face today the
challenge that ball would pose us to us
as citizens as thinkers as scholars as
students but his citizens this film
reminds us of that I also realize now
that the film shows us how Baldwin was
willing to pay his dues and he'll talk
about this in the film what it meant to
belong in the to America the price that
citizenship requires of us but I also
think that the film honestly shows the
cost that paying that price took on
Baldwin and we shouldn't romanticize the
effort the struggle the sacrifice he
made to show us what America could be in
both its problems and its promises so
that's what I want to say about the film
but let me now tell you about the
filmmakers Karen Thorson is a writer co
producer and director of price of the
ticket and her fellow co-producer is
with us tonight Douglas Dempsey's so
first
Karen 5 Karen and Doug both find their
inspiration and themes at the
intersections of art and social justice
they tell stories about game changers as
they put it on their website artists and
activists who shape history the price of
the ticket was their first
feature-length documentary it was a
worldwide hit when it opened first in
1989 after its initial airing on PBS the
film was screened and honored at over
two dozen countries including such major
venues at Sundance London Berlin and
Tokyo film festivals since then Karen
and Doug have labored continuously to
keep Baldwin's life and legacy alive in
at least two ways that I know about and
that you ought to know about as well for
the 25th anniversary they labored very
hard to have the film remastered into
digital format and to keep the format
alive so if this film can live on for
other audiences to see is no small feat
and we thank you for that vision and
they're also heading up the James
Baldwin project an effort to create
curriculum for the pre-college and
college classrooms all across the United
States so that we can keep learning and
reading about James Baldwin because
though we're lucky to study him here in
a single author seminar that's not
always the case across America and it
certainly isn't the case in high schools
and it's certainly not the case in our
public high schools so the work that
Karen and Doug are doing towards that in
is amazing and we thank you for that so
the way we're going to move through
tonight um Karen will give us some first
words about the film then we'll watch
the film will come back together karen
and i will i'll ask a few questions to
get things going and then we will have
two mics standing in the aisles here and
let's talk and let's think together but
for now Doug thank you
Jackie thank you first of all I think it
sounds amazing when I say it but I think
you're one of the first to talk about
the cost and the title of the film is
the price of the ticket people often ask
about that but yes it did cost James
Baldwin an enormous amount in his life
and and that cost is still playing out
if he were here today well he wouldn't
sound much different than he does in the
film um I also want to mention bill
miles who was our co-producer on the
project he died almost close to three
years ago and he was a very instrumental
part of our lives and our effort and I'm
sorry he can't be here to speak with you
as well he began as an archival well
done why don't ok I'll tell it later I
also wanted to mention very briefly that
we were working with James Baldwin on a
very different project when he was still
alive and then a year and a half in he
died and this film is the result and
I'll tell you stories about that later
to the final thing I want to say is
James Baldwin's American scene just to
show you how much he is relevant I think
to our entire group of citizens the the
writer friendly voice who was way back
when a fifteen-year-old growing up in
New Jersey she went on to become a
wonderful public speaker as well as a
writer but she claims to this day that
James Baldwin is her most important
mentor mentor and she is you know when
she was 15 she was Jewish she was gay
she was growing up in New Jersey she
discovered a book by james baldwin and
as she said I fell in love with his mind
and really I hope that happens to
everyone here
I hope all of you understand that that
was Baldwin himself singing precious
Lord um and the credit was for an album
a lover's question when was that and do
you know anything about that recording
the recording was made by a Belgian
friend of James Baldwin a musician named
David links and so he did indeed record
a whole bunch of songs and interestingly
he had background music he had trumpets
and all kinds of things that were Jimmy
was kind of he sang a cappella and it
was recorded a capella but then David
put all these instruments to it but
because we used it in the film in
Ishmael Reed is is reading from go tell
it on the mountain and talking about the
character in go tell it who is you know
about to alysha elijah hits and hits the
keys we wanted it to be piano so we
Charles Darden of a pianist whom we knew
a friend said I could do the music for
Oh precious Lord this is a very well
known him yes yes so we recorded it with
piano and I apologize to David links it
suited the film better yeah well that
actually leads to one question I wanted
to ask again before you you had hinted
at the very beginning that you had some
stories to tell about the making of a
film but one thing that's really very
striking to me is just as a filmmaker as
a documentarian it just seems that
Baldwin is the ideal subject because he
left you so much material visual to work
with and I'm just curious to hear your
speculations about what how do you
understand his rapport with the camera
because there were certain moments this
time every time when the film takes us
to lotion Laban in Switzerland and
there's that footage of him in the
switch swiss village with the kids i
mean who made that who made that footage
or when he's walking along i presume one
of the banks
in Paris i'm going to romantically
assume the sin um who took that and who
was filming him in st. paul de vence i
mean so can you share some archival
secrets here one and then just shouldn't
think about as a documentarian how do
you understand Baldwin's rapport with
the camera that's a great question um
first of all when we when Jimmy died we
were working on a different project and
we didn't know that we'd be making a
film about him gone and I was working
with the Maysles brothers who made verte
films and so it was very hard for us to
understand how we would make this film
and I kind of thought well he's a writer
baby will find photographs of him
hunched over his typewriter and maybe we
can get some friends and colleagues to
read aloud from his work and and that
really was the idea going in we we were
so shocked it was so unexpected Jimmy
had not told us how sick he was in fact
ice last he died December first of 1987
and I spoke to him that September and I
said I've heard you know over the summer
that you aren't well and how are you
doing and what does this mean for a
project and what can we do and he said
don't worry Karen will be filming by the
end of the year well we were but it
wasn't as expected and we filmed the
first thing we filmed was his funeral
but to to answer your larger question we
very swiftly began to hear about pieces
that had been done about James Baldwin
and this is really the story of Jimmy
it's like what I told you briefly in the
beginning about Fran Lebowitz falling in
love with his mind he had not just a
rapport with the camera but a rapport
with with people it I first studied him
in college the way you guys are here and
and that's when I kind of went oh and he
spoke to me not obviously not because
I'm black but because what I first read
was notes of an
son and he was searching for his own
identity in the pages of that book he's
talked about that struggle and I was
going through my own search for identity
and I related to him more than a lot of
others but he had that ability not just
for the camera but whenever he
encountered someone you mentioned the
footage in Louis lebon in Switzerland
that was not filmed obviously when he
and his lover Lucia were living there
together but just a few years later he
wrote this essay stranger in the village
about being the first black person whom
these villagers had ever met and that
essay was so compelling there was there
was a cameraman who worked for swiss
television few mountains over and he
read this essay and he said I know that
village maybe we can get James Baldwin
who this was Jimmy was in France at this
point so it wasn't as fun like getting
him to come from America so he persuaded
James Baldwin to come back to the
village and he filmed him walking around
but it was it was the context that we
needed to show this village where as
Lucy I said everything was white
mountains the people you know what an
experience for James Baldwin yeah well
that's that's that's helpful to know so
just curious about that and it speaks
for me to me is one of the ways in which
he's so precinct about our present-day
because one might argue again to stick
with this medium medium able for a
minute that Baldwin was you know the
multi-platform author right i mean we
see him in your film moving from print
the essay newspapers to the novel to
photography you know his fluency and his
ease
these mediums is very striking to me
photography cinema television I mean
that that Dick Cavett show I don't know
anybody who could sit with Jimmy Kimmel
you know I don't think a jimmy kimmel
could handle the likes of james baldwin
yesterday the people who were oh but he
knew how to use that medium you know and
its really what I'm going to give a
shout out to one of my students Carlene
yeah no name in the streets no name in
the streets you were writing about the
ways in which that late book-length SI
almost reads like a live tweet right
there's just a kind of stream of
language and his Baldwin is trying to
get his head around how to write about
the assassinations right they come one
after the other and he's trying to find
a way for language to make human sense
of all of this laws which is the
situation we're in today today yeah yeah
yeah but the ways in which tweeting
might have been aight cuz i've always
wondered actually could baldwin have
survived in the age of Twitter because
his sentence isn't longer than 140
characters but your way of thinking
about the stream of thinking that that
is tweet light in a certain kind of
sense so there's a way in which he his
form right stretches out into our time
so it's those are that was one set of
questions that seeing the film this time
around spark for me but did you were
there more stories you wanted to tell us
about one of them I think one of the
essential stories is really what what
Jimmy was trying to do in the last years
of his life he had a book that he was
writing it was to be called remember
this house and it was going to be
because it never got finished his memoir
of of the civil rights movement and we
were going to film him in the process of
researching it we I worked with Albert
Maysles and and cinema verite was what
we did and so we were going to follow
Jimmy as a teacher up and Amherst as a
man researching his book down in the
south and we
going to visit the very close friends
and colleagues whom he had from that era
and then his idea which tells you really
what he cared about and and I think it
says relevant it was then as it is today
he was going to intercut the memoir of
civil rights movement with three
specific interviews and the interviews
were to be with the the son of martin
luther king the son of Medgar Evers the
daughter of Malcolm X he was friends
with all of their parents he knew these
kids he had literally bounced them on
his knee when shortly after they were
born and he cared terribly as as it says
in the film about people your age and he
cared even more to the point about
progress and so the question that he was
going to ask the first question without
preparing these these young people was
and while our cameras were rolling this
was the plan he was going to ask them
was it worth it for your father to be
assassinated I don't even you know how
do you get hit with that question and
how do you answer it and how do you deal
with the fact that your father was
assassinated the whole thing is more
than you can bear and yet people are
being gunned down almost daily so that I
should add that there's a film that I
have yet to see that is made by Haitian
filmmaker it just premiered at the
toronto international film festival it's
going to be at the New York Film
Festival and it's documentary it's
called I am NOT your negro it is about
James Baldwin and his relationship to
Martin Luther King and Malcolm X and
it's about remember this house it's
about the book that Jimmy never wrote in
Samuel Jackson reads leads well that
will be exciting they'll have to figure
out class how to get to that and anybody
else or a trip to the New York Film
Festival well speaking of progress one
question I had this time around I'm
curious to know your thoughts about
Baldwin's relationship with his mother
because so often when we think about
Baldwin and the
in which his family the genealogy the
relationships influenced him David
speaks so marvelously and movingly up
movingly about his relationship with
Baldwin but the father's is kind of to
temec you know negative force right but
nonetheless impels belt Baldwin to right
we talked a lot about this with Hilton
Al's so this is to encourage you to come
to all of these talks but I'm curious to
know more about his mother and that's a
way to and I want to display get out of
thinking about Baldwin and feminism but
we'll get there next but let's talk
about his mother folks his mother was an
absolutely central force at bottom was
gracious enough in his writing to call
his stepfather his father but the man
who was so hard on him was not actually
his his own father and it it really
isn't hasn't been revealed who his real
father was but his mother came from
Maryland to New York as a an unmarried
pregnant woman and she met the Reverend
Baldwin and eventually married him and
bore eight children and Jimmy was the
oldest but his mother and he had this
extraordinarily close relationship and
as the other kids did obviously that was
their mother but I think the most
important thing that she gave him she
taught him over and over through every
word and example that she could offer
that all men are brothers that comes
from his mother that is there was we do
these conversations with Jimmy we call
them where we show the film and talk to
people and there was one young woman who
said I I think Jimmy was a futurist and
that phrase stuck with me because i
think it was his mother who taught him
to be a futurist they both had the
ability to see the essential meaning
that love was the answer and no matter
whether it was in and out of fact in or
out of fashion that was that was where
we actually had to go in order to save
ourselves
and I think that's what he took with him
from her I think his his stepfather
preached but his his mother just exuded
it the future this notion of the future
didn't do you or do we know anything
about the ways in which she might have
created space for him to literally right
ah because I that was that when she's
interviewed in the kitchen was that you
know everybody asks that okay all right
I wouldn't let myself be on camera but
that was a journalist from ABC TV as a
matter of fabricated but that was his
mother in the kitchen she said I knew he
had to write and she she was willing
even though she couldn't help him
financially they had nothing they didn't
have enough clothes to keep themselves
warm in winter feeding nine kids and but
she knew he had to write she always
supported him she she read everything
encouraged him and right to thee when we
showed the rough cut of our film of the
schomburg center for research and black
black culture and in harlem the whole
Baldwin family attended and virtus
Baldwin his mother was there and
beforehand I spoke with her and I said I
hope this won't be too difficult and I
knew she was grieving and that we had
her in the film as you see I was nervous
about it but she's crying and then in
the church and I we debate it but we
kept it in and then so we're showing the
rough cut and it really wasn't quite
finished most of the film was there we
didn't have the credits and but what we
did have we knew we were going to have
Oh precious Lord Jimmy singing over the
end and so when it got to that the
screen went black because there was
nothing there but should we turn it off
should we let it sing and we decided
well we should let it play and so on
this absolutely pitch black theater
because there was no light coming from
the screen you heard Jimmy singing o
precious Lord and then you heard this
this kind of whale this
feigning cry begin and we realized it
was coming from Jimmy's mother and again
do we turn it off what do we do and
finally we just let it go so there was a
subscriber you you had the song and you
have the mother wailing over the loss of
her son oops and I went up to her
afterwards and said I don't know whether
that was absolutely the right thing to
do and I'm so grateful because we do
need truth and their relationship is a
beauty
you know how bald one talks later about
how he's got to be involved with life
and and people and not just go a
hideaway to write and I to extrapolate
his mother must have created some of
that because we've heard how he had to
help take care of all the siblings even
as he was trying his early writing and
when he came back to these new york
apartments of the family after he had
made a name for himself in writing what
aishah the nephew and TJ niece and
nephew were telling us all the time is
how what a salon it was of all the
nieces and nephews in the kids and he
never came back and tried to hide away
at all it was all about interacting with
his family at large so I have a feeling
she must have set that tone from the
start she helped them encourage him to
write but he didn't go off and become
escape escapist from his immediate
family and his immediate cause when you
shared that story I want to think a
little more about the question about
feminism I wanted to raise but what I
would hint at is that I sometimes find
as a reader of Baldwin's work attention
between the kinds of biographical
accounts I hear of how the kind of got
what I take to be a gala tarian open
loving supportive relationships with
women romantic and not like Maya Angelou
you know what what a friend would a
friend what a friendship and I'd be very
curious okay research cluster topic
class ah that her papers are now at the
schaumburg and are available and it
might be interesting to read their
correspondence and to see what's there
but but when you turn to the fiction
the segment from blue sir mr. Charlie
and juanita soliloquy which is so
powerful and so complex I still found
myself kind of wow that the testimony of
a black woman in this moment is to you
know to be pregnant and that is going to
be the kind of summation of a kind of
act of protest on her part to atone
Richard's death and so there's a certain
kind of way in which you Baldwin
conception of the human Baldwin's
conception of progress it might just be
an artifact of his time in his
generation to always think in
masculinist terms or two right you know
all men are brothers that's the bottom
line you know by the 70s one could say
well you know we do have the
nomenclature of sisters so what are your
thoughts about God so meant so many but
that's such a great question I've so
rich when i watch the film Giovanni's
Room published around 1956 he finished
it in 54 i think it was fifty one or two
that and this public this book had to be
published in England because America
wasn't ready for it remember that so in
England homosexuality had just been
outlawed I think in 52 I mean made legal
I mean it was illegal up until 52 so he
was writing about something that was you
could go to jail for not just be killed
by people who didn't like you but you
can actually be tried and sent to prison
so there was that and I think he had for
a long time the need to present himself
as male i think it was less that he was
psychologically trained to be male i
think he was required by society for
self-preservation for the preservation
of those he was with for instance when
you watch the Dick Cavett interview he
says my women my children my knees my
nephew well his women he does he did
have someone whom he loved I mean he
hadn't he says in his one of his his
interview moments that he loved a few
men and he loved a few women and that's
really all that saved his life
and it is true that there were women and
someone's writing a book about this I
believe there were women in his life
whom he he thought should I marry this
person I think in the long run his
homosexuality was a stronger urge but I
think society gave him reason to try and
talk about his women and yet the Lionel
men are brothers that's almost biblical
true true but I would push against that
a little bit to say that by the time
he's giving these interviews which I
suspect is that you know in the 70s even
even in the nationalist rhetoric we have
you know there's the language of
brothers and sisters and so that's just
something I wrestle with and I was
curious to know what you think you
certainly called my Angelo his sister
right and he certainly spent probably
more time with men than women so there's
both I I don't fault him too much on
that I I think it's an interesting thing
to analyze but there are those words
that are scattered throughout the film
right you can write and then they're
interesting figures in his you know
fiction like Tish in tissue Bonnie yet
Titian Fania in if Beale Street could
talk which i think is less strident than
Ishmael Reed characterizes it to be that
would be my argument and Ida in another
country very different powerful kinds of
life and in in particular because you
mentioned them at the end of blues for
mr. Charlie they let me be pregnant I've
often thought that and the story of
Titian if Beale Street could talk both
of them are dealing with what his mother
dealt with the being pregnant and not
married and he had to think about that I
I so wish that I'd been able to ask him
more about that i wish i'm sure a lot of
people do there there were
murs that his real father was a poet and
died in prison that's a very romantic
notion I've no way nobody has any proof
but he had think about the fact that he
was basically a but back in the day it
was a bastard yeah right right and so
let me be pregnant was giving voice to
something I think he did he respected
his mother so much that had to be part
of the package yeah okay okay that makes
sense um I want to point out we've got a
couple of mics up here and I'm noting
the time so if you have a question or a
thought a comment um give it shape and
make your way over to the mics if you
want to share that with us and have a
discussion so just putting that out
there and i think one last question
that's burning in my mind one of the
great things about this film and it
still works for me this is like the
fourth time i've seen it and it still
works for me that you move through the
arc of his literary career but you use
the books as a way into so much about
politics about the new of the time um
but it's also it allows us to think
about this issue of the early Baldwin
versus the late fall when you know the
what the effect that politics and
activism has on his art and I'm curious
to know having lived with this film now
for 25 years and thinking about your own
artistic practice I mean what's your
take on that when you think about the
moment we're in right now politically
what is it that you think art can do
whether it's documentary filmmaking of
the sort that you and Doug pursue when
you think about the print culture or
digital culture mediums that are
available to us now I mean what's your
take on that
I think there have been some studies
that said documentary films can actually
drive people back to books and I
certainly know from showing this film a
lot of people say well what should I
read first so those there's that what do
you tell them oh another country often
or the family war or the fire next time
that's awesome because another country
was amazingly accessible it became a
best-seller it was widely read by people
of all races and beliefs and every was
it was shocking it was steamy and sure
is that and you know that if you like
novels that gets you in if you prefer
nonfiction I mean the first one I read
was notes of a native son and i happen
to be rereading it right now because of
the curriculum work we're doing and it
just blows me away he's just so good
yeah but I would also say right now some
of our screenings have been involved in
mates in prison and when you read if
Beale Street could talk this is it could
be written now it's about a 19 year old
girl who who's pregnant who was engaged
to be married and her her fiance is
arrested for absolutely unjustified
reasons and goes off to prison and the
book is her visiting him in prison
dealing with the fact that she's
pregnant dealing with the family dealing
with the courts and the cop who is
described in the reading by my aunt look
this just sounds like now so much of
what Jimmy does or wrote and said feels
like now so art what does art do I got
it except us examine ourselves maybe we
get to understand ourselves better when
an artist takes the time to pick stuff
apart in our case I was a conduit I I
happen I love I like to write I like to
read and I like putting things together
but what I had to work with once we
found these incredible
pieces of our tribal stuff from all over
the world they literally came from 15
different countries he was so real the
materials yeah we found there's hundreds
and thousands of clips and audio tapes
and so on that came from all over the
world those are at the schomburg center
for research in fact black culture but
the ones we used it we got to use Jimmy
telling his own story that was the gift
that was the extraordinary gift and you
put it together so well yeah yeah please
you talked about you talked about the
politics and the writer the early
Baldwin in the later Baldwin and and you
also as I said I was so pleased when you
talked about the cost your introduction
tonight the cost was a vote as it is for
many artists you fall in and out of
favor you're hot then you're not and and
then James Baldwin's case because he
wasn't able to just cultivate his art in
some ivory tower somewhere but he was
forced by the nature of the the what our
society was going through and putting
him through he had to address things
that might not have been as a chosen
topic and and then he got criticized
because he never let go of what his
mother taught him he kept emphasizing
the importance of love and brotherhood
sisterhood he kept saying you know I
believe in the New Jerusalem and yet
people like a Merry baraka we tried to
interview people who had criticized him
and they had very strongly but when they
got in front of our camera they praised
it my last question yet says you know if
you read what a merry Baraka in Ishmael
Reed in Eldridge Cleaver had to say
about James Baldwin not he was so it was
just dragged across the coals and
treated as not radical enough and that's
why the Futurist statement matters to me
so much because it answers that question
it wasn't that he had to be so radical
right then it was
he was actually looking ahead past the
time when we needed to be radical to
where we might actually find a solution
and he was offering that solution and he
never he never let go and in spite of it
all that's the cost and that's the early
Baldwin the late Baldwin sure he skipped
gates writes about it in one of his
essays and kind of saying well you know
Jimmy's earlier writing mattered more
later on he was trying a little too hard
to be more radical he probably was
trying hard well for those of you who
were at the the Tuesday discussion with
Hilton Al's I actually have an argument
about that because actually like the
what I call the formlessness and it's
and that's a term he uses in no name in
the street it's the formlessness of
history in the late 60s 68 to 72 that
leaves him undone but he's still
searching for how to describe that
moment what kind of literary form could
he summon up to address that kind of
formlessness right when history seems
deranged right and what's really
striking Lin arilla Scott makes this
argument but I you know I agree with it
in and others is well Robert Reid far oh
you met in Paris uh that when you look
at all of Baldwin's late fiction there's
always it's always set in the world of
art making from another country right
right another country who are the main
characters Rufus is a jazz drummer right
Ida it becomes a blues singer the vol
dough is struggling to write the high
art novel and richard has written the
middlebrow bestseller and feels guilty
that he's making a lot of money off of
his work right and and funny and if Bill
Street cook talk as a sculptor would
write write write and these were the
people he graduated
naturally as well yes yes but I think
and this is where I my own take is that
that those are people he was gravitating
towards yes those are the people who
were clearly communing with him and st.
Paul devans but that what they're
teaching Baldwin is to ask the question
of the novel form of prose narrative
well how can the novel draw people
together in communion the way that live
theater does right can you can you can
you imagine a novel form but gets that
works on you kinetically such that you
have the kind of immediacy and the end
the ephemerality that comes with it the
ganas right a performance how do you
make that happen in a print novel that's
gonna stay and he writes about so then
you write a novel that's really quite
loose and hard to follow really which
yeah yeah which all of the late fiction
is but he was working on another play
with the welcome table when he died and
he writes very eloquently about how the
first play he saw just knocked him back
he always had a love of an appreciation
of theatre yes absolutely that's my
point he has an appreciation of theatre
he has an appreciation of photography he
tells us in the autobiographical notes
of notes of a native son I want to be a
filmmaker I want nothing so much as they
have you know make experimental films
with the 16-millimeter camera right he
has that's why I say he's like this
multi-platform writer and he's always
thinking about other mediums but at the
end of the day put the prose narrative
whether it's in the service of drama or
fiction or the or nonfiction print the
printed word is his medium that's what I
would go surprise and say that and but
he's trying to figure out how the new
media of the late 60s and 70s can
energize print in writing so what would
he have done with Twitter I know
there we are but then we would get what
we do with no name and street is what
carlene I would just quickly underscore
helps you look at the structure of go
tell it and you he's listening to his
old blues records from when he was a
child later in the film when he's in San
pause you say all these artists are
coming through and informing him and
Bobby sure talks about how they sit at
the table with Miles Davis or Nina
Simone and talking about the structure
of art novels and maybe this is where
he's getting ways it's my to getting
looser and get into yeah your expands
works exactly so I could talk about the
late novels all day so uh any questions
comments you can come up to the mic so
we can all hear you Wow how do you know
how to get that down
thank you so much for making this and
for being here with us I have two
questions the first can you tell us a
little bit about what it was like to
know him personally and to work with him
oh it's awesome to see him on film but
just learning about his legacy I'm sure
knowing him personally it was a gift and
secondly what advice would you give to
women filmmakers who want to maybe make
a social activist change through
filmmaking thank you um first of all I
only met him once it was an
extraordinary once and it lasted for
several hours but he was in France a lot
of the time that we were working
together and then he came through New
York in april of 87 and we had this
meeting where he hung out at this place
called the gingerman was a restaurant
near lincoln center back in the day and
i went and i was you know very proper
and very nervous and waited and waited
and waited and Jimmy did have a habit of
being late but um then all of a sudden
there was this kind of bustle in from
the entrance of the restaurant and in he
walked and of course you instantly knew
who he was I'd um I can still it's
absolutely a palpable omen he he looked
around he figured out who I was and um
headed toward me and his mouth that
smile you see near the end of the film
my first thought was when I first saw
him come in he's tiny which he was and
the second thought was that's Annie he
was the smile was so huge he he just
filled the room and then he talked to me
he made me feel as if I were the center
of his existence for a while and he
answered my questions and he didn't all
of my fears and China's all went away
and I just thought this is when you're
making a documentary what you want most
is some
who is a good storyteller someone who is
good with words and whose light comes
out of their eyes and he had all of that
and he yes his his primary medium is the
printed word but that also is the
primary medium in a way for a preacher
and a performer someone who is so good
with words they they can think on their
feet and it comes out like poetry anyway
um what was your second question advice
for you for all airing film hugely
important ah a lot of the time
persistence Trump's talent and yes
talent is is important and having
something you want to say is important I
would say I've heard so many different
people give excellent advice and it
often is summed up in don't let other
people tell you that your voice isn't
the right voice don't don't let them
condense you into a predictable box
especially when you're beginning that's
when you probably have the most courage
to be original in yourself and
persistence really matters it does help
to suss out what the audience would like
to hear and to pick a topic that you
know interest people beyond your
immediate family but on the other hand
Doug well you know you said about female
filmmaker and right now that's that's
the thing to be I mean you need to come
in saying you need to hear my voice
because ever since Oscars so white last
year it's taken over even popular medium
this concept of wait a minute we're not
hearing from anybody but a tiny narrow
pie slice of demographic so you use that
but hashtag Hollywood so male in the old
days used to have to spend a lot of time
making a film to try to get it to film
festivals to get some buzz now what you
need to do is have a youtube channel and
just find the stuff you want just keep
putting up little bits even if it's just
you talking in a camera about your
concerns are you and your friends you
start any kind of filmmaking and you go
from there and then you support that
with kind of Twitter plow through enough
hashtags till one catch is that people
are connecting that with a YouTube
channel usually as you say some issue
that you think is interesting or
important once an issue is important
people are going to scrub for every
mention of a certain issue to see what
different people are saying if they look
at your YouTube channel and they like
some of the little bits that's how you
get noticed then sometimes you can get a
budget to make something a little more
professional-looking that can go to a
festival but just use social media to be
as a lot of voices anybody else out
there there's a lot of knuckleheads and
you need to shout as loud as they are to
make sure your presided Astoria's herds
well is there expert advice yes hi oh
thank you so much for allowing us to
watch the film it was really amazing I
was really struck by the kinds of public
and private grief but also public and
private joy that was represented in the
documentary so I had two questions the
first is where was Baldwin at the time
that you were working with him towards
the end of his life like did he was he
expressing more of this grief or more of
the joy aspect it was a mix of the two
and I'm thinking about this in
relationship to his responses to the
kinds of unexpected death that he had of
his friends and he's like major public
public figures and the kind of more
expected nature of dying from cancer and
having known that that was going to be
what would be his final like end so I
was wondering if he if you had any
conversations about that or what your
sense was about his mood towards the end
of his life I didn't ask him that as
much as what what resonated for me is
when his close friend and associate up
of Amherst Cynthia Packard reads that
letter I i still am moved to here
because I think it is one of the most
eloquent expressions of a mood before
dying he's writing he says I curl up at
the center of the stillness of the dark
and and it just goes
enemies he's really he's looking ahead
at the journey he's about to make and
he's doing it i don't hear fear I don't
hear grief I know there are people he
hated to leave behind then the grief was
as is often with death the people who
are left behind are the ones who are so
so damaged for a while I I feel as if he
looked at death the way he looked at
life and I do think joy was of one of
the feelings I think he was full of hope
I think he was as he said I'm not in
despair I'm in range time betty was
still enraged right to the end that's a
valuable emotion thank you and then just
my one other question was how did he
talk about his writing did he talk about
his writing or was it mainly talking
about his reflections on society I
rather than answer that I want to say
something else I I just realized that
applies to your first question the day
that Jimmy died a friend of mine called
me at seven in the morning and I just
Karen I just heard on NPR James Baldwin
died in France last night and as I said
I didn't expect it so this was a big
shock and also there goes that film
project by the way but anyway I went
into the office and we all had the news
and a lot of us were in tears and we
just commiserated and figured well no
way this film can be made you can't make
cinema verite about a dead man so we
were grieving but then the point of the
story is that after everybody kind of
well we've got to get back to work I
went over to the little place where we
kept our God our mail we had little
cubbyholes each of us had our name in
the box and I got my mail and in my mail
that day was a letter from James Baldwin
and he had the dated the week before and
it was a very short typewritten letter I
later learned that he had dictated it
and it was type and the letter said dear
Karen I'm sorry to say for reasons of
health I won't be able to participate in
our film project is planned peace Jimmy
and then the period as plan period was
crossed out with a big accident
and writing it said for the time being
now to me that says a lot about what his
attitude was thank you
you spend a bit of time with his brother
on this project i'm assuming could you
talk a little bit about the texture of
the relationship between those two
people and then the kinds of insights
that he was able to offer and how they
shaped your view of Baldwin it was a
beautiful relationship I mean I would
imagine you know that from the film they
had they were born ten years apart and
so the 10 year old Jimmy helped change
David's diapers and and watched him grow
up and literally described how he would
have all of his siblings but David in
particular he would they were very close
he'd have him on one hip and a book in
the other and he read and take care of
the kids but when David describes Jimmy
coming back to from Paris that first
time and where they really became
friends that began a relationship that
lasted literally until the day Jimmy
died and David was there for him he was
he was less verbally articulate he was a
wonderful musician he also was a
bartender at a place called mikal's on
Columbus Avenue in New York and he had a
huge following just because David was
this gregarious you know philosopher
type but very much the common man and he
didn't have pretensions nor was he
bothered in the way that perhaps some
other family members might have been and
I qualify that about his brother and not
first of all it's difficult to be the
sibling of a famous person when you're
only a half-sibling you know did you get
the good genes or not is and then how do
you deal with Fame David gracefully
managed to be both a humble companion
and a protector and that lasted their
lifetime and after Jimmy died David was
the one who made this film possible
without him and wouldn't have happened
there was it took 10 days for Jimmy's
body to be dealt with in France
then the casket with the body came to
the states and the funeral was planned
at st. John than divine and so at this
point based on it really was Jimmy's
letter where he said for the time being
that made me realize wait a minute we
need to make a film and so then it was
the jockeying of getting the funders in
line and what's possible but the family
was you couldn't bother them in their
moment of grief so what do you do and so
they were having a viewing of the open
casket up at a Funeral Home in Harlem
and so we had three camera crews ready
for the next day's funeral without
knowing whether we'd be allowed to film
and the word was no cameras in the
church and st. John and davonne so I I
went to the funeral home I stood in line
the line literally was two-and-a-half
blocks it took hours finally we wind in
past the casket and then the image comes
to mind is rather like The Godfather but
that's not appropriate but they're the
family was sitting in the back at the
end of the line you kind of went through
and look like a wedding you pay your
respects and I wasn't sure how to do any
of this but there was David whom I had
met through Jimmy before and I said hey
you know this is a terrible moment but I
need to ask you do you think we will be
able to film the funeral and he said yes
and I went out to the pay phone and I
called the crew and the next morning we
were at the church and in fact that's
there was a locked camera that was
allowed for an ABC TV feed but it didn't
really capture it and so we were so
fortunate to be able to do that that
made I think all the difference and it
was it was David later I went to see him
and I said should we have some kind of
agreement and he gave me he reached into
a bowl this was at the apartment that he
had in New York that Jimmy would stay in
with a Weber whenever he came to the
city he reached in the bowl and he took
out these three stones that were rounded
pebbles from the South of France a lot
of the beaches are made of stones they
aren't made of sand and these were
stones that Jimmy have gathered and he
said
take these three stones this is our
agreement and I still carry them got him
here today but in terms of relationship
also David many people acknowledged was
really the President Jimmy trusted the
most especially out on the road and it's
a sounding board and person he could
talk to who wasn't after anything other
than Brotherhood and that meant a lot
for every every bit of work that he did
it was we've been told at one point I
asked David what do you think about all
that drinking you know do you feel as if
maybe your brother could have lasted
longer and he said that's what it took
to get him through the night you can't
reproach that he couldn't have done the
work he did he couldn't have coped
without it that was what he needed I
don't fault him
take this question comment and then
maybe one more and then we should call
it thank you very much I have a question
by Baldwin's fluency in relationship to
the French language do you have any
footage of him speaking French or any
other language and I didn't choose to
include it and we didn't there wasn't
any if it had been extraordinarily
important I have since the film with me
was made seeing some things that uh that
would have been good he was very he was
quite fluid he learned French it became
instinctual to him he was very much in
tune with the French culture and I can't
tell you how good his Turkish was he
certainly was very close to many people
in Turkey but his best friends in Turkey
were fluent in English because they had
been in the States so he he was language
was was part of his his his brain worked
well in that regard and the the things
that I've seen more recently he was on
talk shows and certain televisions
commenting on them the mess back in the
States I'm sure he would still be asked
to come and today thank you if there are
no other questions or comments thank you
Karen summoned done
I i would add one thing that is some
your most wonderfully excellently
curated group of people who are coming
over the next couple of months I
encourage everyone to come there people
whom I've had the privilege of working
with and hearing speak and they they
have such interesting takes there there
they too are good with the spoken word
and just we'll have a great group thank
you for that plug-in and towards that
again and again to thanks to Barbara and
Richard Frankie for making this possible
thank you and thanks so much